[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
tim dillon dropped a brand new netflix
special on wednesday and i want to know
what you guys think about it so today's
video we're going through some of the
reactions from you guys the fans the
comedy community seeing what you thought
of tim's new special and also showing
some of the best clips abel said his
talent and skills is elite i do prefer
his podcasts give it an eight gillis was
a 10 for me so this is gonna be a common
theme i feel like comparing his podcast
talent to his stand-up talent but let's
keep going i haven't seen it haven't
heard much from it he didn't really
promote it on other podcasts so it might
be mid or undersell over deliver
that's true he didn't really do the
podcast rounds like we've seen andrew
schultz do or whitney cummings do a few
weeks ago when their podcast came out
and they did literally every single show
podcast in the world but tim's doing a
little bit of the rounds now he's on joe
rogan today on friday and his instagram
has been promoting it non-stop but yeah
he definitely didn't do the typical
comedian i'm gonna go on every single la
podcast to promote my special we're at
war with each other where we should just
be enjoying the spoils of the end of the
empire truly
you should be enjoying people so many
people got killed murdered tortured
maimed for us to have all the nice
things we have do you know how insane it
is to not enjoy it you know how crazy it
is to not enjoy a mcmansion a flat
screen tv a mcflurry you're not picking
what's blood is in the street for those
things and people act like they don't
even matter and they're fighting about
all this [ __ ] it's crazy anyway
that's the truth that's the real truth
nobody wants to hear it but that is the
truth we have a lot of these things are
nice but some of them are ill-gotten
gains fine you know not everybody
picking tomatoes is happy about it but
have you ever had a goo like a nice
jersey thick beef steak tomato it's good
imagine having one and then fighting
with someone about something it's stupid
if there's a hell world going and if
there's not we get reincarnated when
we're a beatles or something but just
enjoy it and nobody wants to enjoy it
and that's what makes me upset is that
we used to have a country built on
enjoyment built on fat stupid people
enjoying the work of a small group of
demons and now we can't even enjoy it
can't even have fun saw him live late
last year completely different set lol
it was really good but when i saw him in
l.a last year he did a set that was far
funnier i was laughing almost non-stop
so a few different people reaching out
saying that this is not the same set
that they saw live this year which kind
of makes sense he's touring something
different than what he's putting on
netflix now either way i'm i'm excited
to see a live set once i can of tim
dillon but i really did like what i saw
on netflix big no said thanks for
letting me know it's out and this is
exactly why you subscribe to joke world
all your comedy news in one place i will
make sure you never ever miss a tim
dillon special think about this big nose
and the 11 people that like this they
could have gone to their grave without
knowing the special was out if not for
subscribing to joke world and that could
be you too you could be next you could
be the next big nose so please take a
second subscribe to joke world like this
video
send it to your mom cody smith said i
loved it i was there front row in my
wheelchair parentheses sometimes you get
a win in a wheelchair and then there was
a response to this that i thought was so
funny ugh lucky
thinking oh he's lucky that he saw it in
the front row
my mom was in one two and got the
parking thing and now that i'm an adult
and i miss the time we spent together
parking close to the walmart and stuff
so that's just some wholesome wheelchair
content between uh cody smith and
raztek's 666.
plague doctor said read a great comment
about it tim is one of those people who
burns his best material for the podcast
and it shows now this is interesting
because in a previous video i did say
that tim and theovan are some of the two
comedians maybe the only two comedians
who are just so unique and in their own
lane and so impossible to replicate on
what they do in their podcast whether
that be interviewing another comedian or
a lone solo rants
stream of thought stream of
consciousness there there's no one
better than tim dillon at this maybe
theo van
but the topics that he was including in
his uh specials are also things that
we've heard him talk about on the
podcast before he closed with the airbnb
story he talked about fast food workers
and sonic and it's still similar topics
that would be on his podcast but
i almost feel like his podcast is like a
version of the news like he's talking
about whatever is the most current topic
available so that could be hard to
translate into an hour special that you
have to work on for many many months and
even years to keep that relevant what's
going on
are they teaching two-year-olds about
gender theory maybe i don't know there's
always one school that they find in like
san francisco
there's always one school they use as an
example
where the teacher's in front of the kids
and she's like this is my labia
and tonight i'm gonna make it a [ __ ]
and your homework is to name my new car
and you go that is a bit much
that is excessive
but then like everything else in our
country it swings crazy left a crazy
right
flora's got a new bill people call it
the don't say gay bill one of the
provisions in this bill that they
dropped was that teachers were gonna
have to out kids as gay to their parents
within six months
which is horrible
but hilarious
when you think of the calls the teachers
would have to make
hey mr morris how are you yeah
i'm todd's english teacher
yeah he's doing great no no problems
he's doing great
he is very close with another boy though
they laugh a lot they take the bus
together
oh that's his brother
okay no nothing nothing ah
nothing at all how are you are you good
yeah i'm just checking up on everybody
i would call i'd give it no context
hey mrs miller
your daughters are less
let them figure it out
you know
it also makes teachers look horrible you
know
i watched your son jerk off with his
friend i think they're gay
no i did i i filmed it i knew you
wouldn't believe me
do you want to see it it's my job
no it's my job
i'm a teacher
brendan smith said was tremendous the
best i've seen on netflix this year he
talked about food a lot though which
makes sense good fat joke by brendan i
haven't seen him stand up and don't know
if i want to but i've listened to every
one of his pods he should have kept his
mouth shut
it's a good inside joke but i don't
understand if you've never seen a
stand-up but listen to every single one
of his pods why you don't know if you'd
even want to check it out it seems like
you're a big fan and i'd go watch this
special on netflix his podcast and ymh's
are my favorite of all time idk about
the special though it'd be better if the
freeloader leech of a producer of his
wasn't in the background laughing ha ha
so ben avery did produce this special
which was pretty funny obviously there's
a great back and forth between tim and
ben and it's funny that they mentioned
the ymh's because i just saw tim dillon
on the your mom's house live the same
day that a special dropped he was there
having a good time promoted it briefly
and
the things that he was saying behind
that pay wall about the special i don't
know if you've seen the ymh live but if
you have you know what i'm talking about
and that is classic tim dude the live
shows like you're allowed to show
whatever you want you're allowed to say
whatever you want there's no youtube
restrictions there's no anything that's
why tom segura loves the heavy segment
on his live show so much because he can
find the most [ __ ] up clips in the
world and has no
strings attached no repercussions for
showing them at all so the live show was
awesome now we're just doing a random
ymh live plug but tim dillon on there
talking about his special
if you know you know this lady rated it
a 7 out of 10. this guy said his podcast
is better but his podcast is just so
good it's saying his podcast is better
is is not even really fair because
you're comparing like the top echelon of
podcasting to a netflix special like
that's it's not a fair fight his podcast
is better than most people's netflix
specials most comedians specials
the tim dillon show is funnier than
if not all i can't think of one special
that i'd say i'd rather keep the access
to watching this special and give up
watching tim's podcast
that in no world is a fair trade for any
special so
his podcast is better it's kind of an
unfair thing to say but
i technically agree there's a good
number of standups i legitimately like
better in podcasts and or a considerably
more natural state tim is one of them
so kind of what we just said
yeah
i guess so but
this is the job is getting up there and
putting on your 48-minute special
because he is a comedian um and a
polycaster but you got to keep
the comedian part in your name you got
to get these specials out there were so
many other comedians that came out
supporting the special too posting all
over their social medias mainly
instagram to go watch the special he was
reposting all those on his instagram
story so although he didn't go on that
many podcasts to promote it he still had
his friends in the comedy community
helping him kind of in the same way
instead of going on their show for an
hour hey just post this on your
instagram story and it gets the same
message across hey hey folks just here
to tell you to check out tim dillon's
new special on netflix he's got aids
tim's awesome [ __ ] blew my top off
couldn't believe what i [ __ ] saw way
better than the alex jones tweets
christina said amazing he is my hero and
lewis said i absolutely love tim
dillon's special did you yes or yes also
real quick if you could please follow
jokeworld on instagram and hear me out i
know it's annoying but we're only 800
people away from 10 000 followers on
instagram and every day we try to
feature a new stand-up comedian more of
an open micro unknown guy they send in
their clips their best 60 seconds and we
feature it on our instagram page for
more people to see to give them a bigger
platform trying to help comedy think
about kill tony but in an instagram form
that's kind of what we're doing and
we're only 800 people away from getting
to ten thousand i know it's stupid it's
just instagram it's a number whatever
but i can't help that i want to get
there and so if 800 of you could just go
in the link of this description
just click the link to the instagram
follow i don't care if you ever interact
with us again just
i know 800 people are going to see this
just please do it
[Music]
you